this actor began his career in reality
tv and followed up with a series of
acting roles in series like eli stone
before nabbing the biggest one of his
career without a detective nick
burkhardt
[Applause]
this california boy began acting just
after kindergarten and hasn't stopped
since
his breakout role came last year when he
was cast as scott mccall and anthony
[Applause]
his former members second city and
joined stints on the big bang theory in
warehouse 13 before joining a little
drama on nbc in 2010 as the dude glenn
he also rocks your cheekbones
[Applause]
it was so immensely painful when you
agreed put those hundred arrows through
john's nose heart thank god
[Applause]
this actor generated more than a few
headlines this year when it was
announced he would step down from his
ridiculously popular role headline
doctor whoa
[Applause]
it's clear guys that you have some fans
out there but i want you to fess up for
us
who do you know among the panel are some
of these guys strangers have you
actually seen each other's work
well me and matt know each other both in
london yeah
[Applause]
they're all wonderful
all right so one thing you guys all have
in common is that you play these uh
iconic characters on high concept genre
series let's talk about how you felt
when you first offer these roles matt
let's start with you
oh blimey um
intimidated i think it was it was uh i
mean it's sort of wonderful to be part
of a show that has such a legacy behind
it and um
i don't know it was strange because
there was such an uproar with my age
and everyone was like he can't be the
doctor he's like nine
so it was it was bizarre but you know i
guess you just sort of try and stay true
to your creative instincts
okay how about you
well like you i kind of just got an hbo
pilot through and i love hbo and what
they do and
i read it and it was the most
bizarre thing i've ever read in my
entire life
and
none of us had any idea what it would be
like or whether it would work and
so i i kind of went into it
not really knowing and it all worked out
pretty well
yeah
and i love doing it
stephen
was it's crazy it's been a crazy ride uh
i just moved to la about four months
prior as my first pilot season and uh
i was just happy to have a job and
that job just turned into something uh
really fun and amazing and
honestly it's been like the greatest
grad school for me uh just in terms of
just the business and acting is awesome
yeah
tyler oh yeah
[Applause]
and i was super excited to get it first
of all it was teen wolf
and
i'm like wow michael j fox has some huge
shoes to fill and
um
i uh
and i was super stoked because with mtv
i love mtv
and i grew up watching it and it was
just the role itself is just
by far the coolest thing i've ever done
in my entire life and i'm just so
grateful and happy and
stoked to be on this panel
[Music]
all right david how are you i just
wanted to speak for the fans tyler and
say you are so sexy
[Applause]
uh yeah
you know you get a bunch of pilots and
uh you read them and
grim was a very bizarre pilot as a lot
of sci-fi is
but it became
some great guys like david greenwald who
you know was one of the boys in charge
of
buffy and angel
[Applause]
and
yeah you get very nervous but you feel
very blessed to get the role
is there a downside to playing genre
roles that fans care so deeply about
that know so much about
uh the fan fiction is pretty nuts
sometimes
so it's kind of down it's not a downside
but it gets pretty gnarly thank you guys
by the way
i love you
steven you asked answer this because a
year ago anyone who follows the comic
books your character
had a tough road i won't spoil it for
anybody
does that is that like a
ticking clock over your head i mean
what's going on um honestly like in
terms of the source material for me
all i could think about when i was
first getting into it was just don't
mess it up you know because i know how
how
me as a fan would have taken if someone
just took a role just ruined it
i think i didn't do that
so
with
what's coming up or what might happen
the show is kind of doing its own thing
as well so i'm just trying to
do the best job i can i guess
can you address this too because
obviously anyone can find out
by reading the internet what happens in
the in the novels and they jump ahead i
mean how does that
haunt your soul while you do this
yeah it's um i've i read the books
really quickly because i wanted to know
exactly what happened and how long i
lived for an et cetera
just don't know with george no one knows
with george
um but it's uh
i don't know it's
it it's great it can be nerve-racking
getting into
getting to play a character that's so
beloved in the such
you know such
amazing novels and people hold so close
to their chest and love so dearly and
and but you i find as an actor you have
to separate yourself
from
people's expectations and just take the
character that you've read and known
and just trust
the way you read them is the way that
people see them and
um
i don't know it's also great for for us
i guess that we get to
revisit these characters year after year
and kind of grow with them
and
and development over time it's one of
the great things about tv at the moment
i think
thank you
we will be taking your questions too if
you'd like to line up
right now matt you're among friends
you made some headlines this year please
explain to us
what the hell happened why you decided
to make a change in your life
[Applause]
um ah you know cause i kind of figure
it's been four years and the best four
years has been it's been wonderful it's
been a privileged work under stephen
moffatt but i think you know you've got
to go you've got to go
trends
[Music]
it's sad i'm going to miss it and i'm
going to miss comic-con as well
yeah it wasn't an easy choice you know
it wasn't an easy an easy decision to
come to but
i don't know you can't play it forever
and because it's such a
and look they'll get someone amazing
they'll get someone brilliant to do it
and um
you know and that's the great thing
about this show is that it it continues
and
and the strength of it survives and it
will get better and it will get bigger
and all just keep going and you'll
forget about me
all right from the outside you guys seem
like you've got the best jobs in
hollywood but now's your chance to burst
our bubble shows the ugly underbelly of
your job what is the unsexiest thing
about what you do i'm gonna start with
you david
the un wow
um
we have very early call times our um
uh our
circadian rhythms are destroyed did i
get that word right circadian yeah
and um what's the unsexiest thing
i don't know like you can't even if you
have something hanging out of your nose
everybody's watching you all the time so
there's no you can't look cool ever you
know on set everybody just kind of has
their eyes on you
yeah yeah learning lives
generally tyler do you have a story
anything unsexy about you i i i don't
i i don't uh have any chest hair but i
do grow nipple hair
i don't always shave it before a
shirtless scene so usually one of the
executive producers shaves it for
i me know why he just wants to so
that's probably that's the only that's
going to be interesting
[Laughter]
stephen what about you
uh
unsexiest thing um
there's a lot of bugs
in atlanta and
they like the warmest parts of bodies
on how you're feeling um
[Laughter]
[Applause]
let's just just say like it's it's
happened before
my one sex scene was possibly the most
humiliating experience of my life
i broke i broke my ankle at the time so
i i had to crouch on to set naked
on crutches not being able to
hide anything
and there's a hundred there's a hundred
people
just
trying not to laugh
but it's um yeah that was
[Applause]
vanity pouches are not sexy
all right last but not least what about
the unsexiest thing
blimey
karen gillan in the morning
every time i finish work it's like
because you think there's so many lines
and you've got to learn like every night
it's a constant
is that unsexy no
i don't know i mean
it's
doctor who's not a massively sexy show
yeah you got riding quite sexy shows and
i was just like
all right one more i'll take a question
from the crowd you know we have this
ongoing series in the magazine that we
call watched about it there's gotta be
something a commercial
okay a lifetime series anything like
that
this one with lifetime
i'm just saying
um all right thank you charlie look at
your to go first i was just i was
thinking out loud okay
okay let me think uh
i mean i'm i'm pretty proud of
everything that i do
i i used to recreate um
you guys know the show jackass
i used to do that with my little brother
and uh
we would do really stupid stupid things
did you hurt yourself oh not really no i
never really hurt myself but i would do
the more gross stuff
did you lie to fart
yeah well yeah along those lines yeah
it's stuff to do with my butt definitely
it's all solid
i got
this close when i when i first got out
to la and i really wanted this
commercial but i didn't get it and thank
god
because my first line was
my girlfriend's line was no my first
line was
i have genital herpes
and then she would say and i don't and
then we would both say and we want to
keep it that way
i'm glad i didn't get that one
can you chop that
guys all right on that note let's take a
question
first up wow
[Applause]
my question is i have a lot of
spoilers in here and a lot of adventures
that happened and some that
we never saw so
if you were able to film another episode
after the finale
what adventure would you have the doctor
go
that's a very good question um
stephen moffitt was actually pitching
all the ideas for next season to me last
night which was uh which was hard um
what would i do i have i don't know
really i've
always there's i mean there's so many
isn't there i we did dinosaurs i was
really into that
um i've always wanted to do something
like with sinatra
something based around i don't know
frank sinatra be an alien or something i
don't know
um or i don't know maybe go forward i've
got to think about it where would you go
that's more interesting what what would
you like to see done
atlanta oh atlantis yes bingo we have a
winner
actually been done before though but it
would be good to do it again
down okay nice
go see cumberbatch
[Applause]
go ahead
hi my name is christos
uh my question is for the whole panel
what is your favorite one that you've
gone up against
favorite villain that we've gone up
against
uh i i if anyone saw last season at teen
wolf there was a panama
he's like a giant uh wear lizard almost
uh and so far that was my favorite um
because it wasn't mostly cgi it was a
suit that
the guy had to wear and it was literally
like he had to wear it every day for 17
hours sometimes and it got really stinky
so it was uh that was that was always
interesting and
fun but it looked cool it looked awesome
on camera so
yeah
well i can't remember this is in the
middle of last season and i know kate
you just got done working with sasha the
guy who plays the captain
got in this like epic all-out you know
no-holds-barred kind of fight
and um
he
i usually end up fighting a stunt guy
but in this case i fought sasha royce
who plays the captain and he kicked me
so hard
in the thigh
yeah is that true you fight him all the
time
um
so yeah so i ended up with like this big
it looked like a horse that kicked me in
the thighs of massages big dress shoe
imprinted
yeah do you have one mine just naturally
follows because i've just done a film
massager and
he kicked me elsewhere
many times and he's my favorite villain
that i've got
against he's great he's a great guy yeah
merle
yeah
[Applause]
might be either a weeping angel
or
all silence next go ahead
i think um
just just being where we are now like
this being here and
and seeing everybody here for us and
that's that's that's definitely impacted
me the most uh just just throw it girl
[Applause]
so thanks guys
do you want to interact with fans on
social media i mean how do you feel
about that
doing that because it can get very
personal they can find you
they have
i know i love it i i'm a huge a huge
twitter and instagram
freak
so
i love i love having conversations with
fans i think that's one of the coolest
things and i think one of the only
reasons why twitter should be around
um so i think that's i think that's
really fun and really cool and a little
personal but it's it's it's cool at
times you know it's fun and you know
when to hold back and win that you know
do you have anything about no i i i
don't have twitter actually although i
did i ventured into twitter just to to
do like a thank you sort of message to
everyone because
they've been very supportive for the
last four years and that's
as far as it goes for me i'm i'm not a
tweeter or a facebook or a or a grammar
i'm a real grump when it comes to
technology
i'm like just write me a letter
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i don't trust myself i'd end up writing
something yeah at some point that would
come back and find yourself
stephen walking dead is the perfect uh
interactive social media show so are you
a part of that uh i do have a twitter i
just say stupid things
most of the time about like detroit in
sports how much i love them and uh i
don't know why anyone follows me
[Applause]
so
sorry
david i gotta cover you do you tweet i
do tweet i tweet it it keeps me uh and
those lonely days on set it's always
nice to know that some people find me
charming
but dwindling number of them that do but
uh
yeah i tweet i enjoy interacting with
all of the fans definitely
all right next bravo
i'd know for for me it was uh
i don't know if it if it's brave or
cruel but when he had to leave
her yeah
right
had to be brave because he was doing it
for her essentially and
but it's yeah that was that was his
bravest moment it wasn't a sword fight
it was leaving the girl
i think uh well it was probably i think
probably uh something to do with the
media pond really and
[Applause]
or one of my i don't know what the
bravest one was one of my favorites to
sort of look back on is remember in the
pandora grovelands when he when he
stands
[Applause]
um
it's been fun to play glenn just to see
him grow from the kid to where he is now
and i think that
the the moment that he kind of broke was
uh that chair sitting
it was fun for as
as an actor as well just to go
uh dan zach i'm our director you're just
like i'm just going to film you just go
nuts and we'll just capture it
it was awesome
for me i think it was the scene where
scott um tries to save deaton from from
being killed
he has to break through or he tries to
break through this barrier of mountain
hash which
werewolves can't
so he didn't know what was going to
happen to him he didn't know if scott
was gonna die i didn't know if this was
gonna kill him but uh there was a flash
of like his red eyes which means
which means that uh there's a flash of
an alpha in him a true alpha so that
means he's very heroic and i think that
that really
uh was a huge heroic moment for scott
i just want to start this by saying
tyler for all the fans you're just so
sexy
[Applause]
it's not fun anymore isn't that not just
getting strange i can't think of a
specific instance i think that any time
like a character and always with us
probably having some kind of fight scene
you know
breaks a rule of their own and i
remember you know i i started out the
series as this
very down the middle kind of cop guy
detective guy and then
and i can't think of the specific scenes
or but whenever i started
kind of going rogue doing things outside
of the police
you know those are defining moments
definitely
[Applause]
my yeah i i mean i'm i'm i was really
close to karen and arthur we were a
little team and um and the same with
jenna you know
it's because you're with them
you know day in and day out and um so
absolutely yeah karen arthur and and
jenna and then i've been very fortunate
to sort of have some cool cats james
corden is now a good friend of mine and
[Music]
tony karan yeah a lot of people but
karen arthur and jenna i would say
next up
question is for the whole panel
i was just wondering if you regret or
really are happy that you chose to take
on such big roles and that you'll
probably be known for them for the rest
of your career
[Applause]
i mean i hope that's not the case i mean
i love being scott i love playing scott
he's one of my favorite roles
ever and i probably will be for the rest
of my life but um yeah he's a super
iconic uh character and role um but i
mean hope i hope i can no no regrets no
regrets at all um but i don't i don't
think that i'll be
at least i don't i hope not i won't be
tied down to this character for the rest
of my life and if i do then that's
awesome because i think he has a great
cool awesome fun role to play and it's
really fun to see him grow and and and
mature
so
no regrets no regrets at all i love i
love this job more than anything
thank you man
i think i think that kind of nails it
you know it's it's that's it yeah no no
it's uh no regrets honorable parts for
all of us and you know it's cool man and
hopefully something else will employees
one day
kid yeah i mean i feel the same if
you're lucky enough to be in a tv show
that has done
something really well and and you are
recognized as that person then you're a
lucky actor
and um
and of course you want to do other
things but if you've now if you've kind
of got one role that you're remembered
for then
that's a great thing that's that's
really good
next question
stephen you jump in um yeah you know
i think um something that i kind of
relate to with glenn is just kind of his
resilience um he always kind of bounces
back and
lord knows i've had a lot of uh
embarrassing moments for myself
throughout my entire life
so
i just i don't know i just kind of take
it in stride and i think
uh
yeah that's what i love about glenn as
well
david
um
you know
we we get paid to brood a little bit
some of us uh
i don't know i don't know i i think that
gosh i have such a bad ad who wants to
go next someone else thank you
uh no no i think um
yeah uh nick has kind of done anything
will do anything for his love juliet and
um
[Music]
even if that means putting himself in
harm's way and i like to think of myself
in that way
kind of
think myself the hero in that way so
hopefully that's how i am
uh
[Applause]
it would have exactly the same type of
music
what i mean i'm clumsy and uh and
you know the doctor is kind of clumsy i
think what this doctor is i don't know
really it's like he's a
thousand-year-old time lord i i don't
know what to begin
he's just a much better
creature than i am
um but he's quite kind i hope i hope
some are unkind you know kindness
time travel i can time travel i just
haven't told anyone i mean
[Music]
yeah i don't know
next step the weeping angel just because
i think uh
yeah i just think it's one of the
cleverest monsters
or maybe the silence but i tell you what
i really liked this season was the
whisper men i thought they were great
they look really scary
what's the scariest to you
the weaving angels good answer
do you know do you know did you know
that if the show appealed to that young
viewer i'm not sure how old he was but
what in england yeah yeah because it's
sort of it's it's it's a show that has
always crushed
kind of generations and it's it's really
interesting to see in the states
actually and i really hope that that
more kids watch over here because
actually i think
essentially that's you know it's kind of
for kids somewhere so
yeah but in the uk
kids digging
go ahead
the creepiest thing
i you know you're it's it's i don't know
i once i got home once and it wasn't
creepy it was just strange but i got to
my front door
and there was a little girl of about 12
in the bush
and she sort of jumped that was like
don't worry i'm not crazy
she was a cool kid though
do you have a creepy is it creepy from
the set or creepy in your life in
general
in the set
oh creepy fans sorry for the moment
such good shorts
so um
yeah you get some pictures and
could things
regarded as creepy
orange you're not going to elaborate
stephen uh i don't know if it's creepy
but i was embarrassed for her a little
bit um
no it was it was she was so sweet but i
was walking down the street in atlanta
and she saw me from maybe like a block
away and she started zombie walking
towards
block so them at least like
so like she it was it was the greatest
thing because i could see her doing it
and halfway through you can see in her
face she's like i regret this decision
but i will
fight the good fight and continue on
the best part is she gets up to me and
she just goes she's like
i'm so sorry
she's really sweet she's not in this
room right now by the way is she anyone
okay
uh for me most of my fans are awesome i
i don't have really too many creepy
experiences um some people some two
girls followed me in my car one time
though and i was like all right you
can't you can't follow me that's super
weird i was on my way to go pick up my
girlfriend and i i like took this like
weird route so they wouldn't know where
i was going and then like eventually
stopped the car and like they drove by
me i gave them like this gangster look
and then they stopped and got out of the
car and it took them forever and i took
a picture with them and i kind of wish i
didn't because i was just like this is
this is weird you don't do that right
so yeah that was really good and you're
fairly creepy my friend
all right one more day would go
yeah you're creepy but you're going for
it yeah
um
uh
it wasn't even an encounter it was just
i live on the ninth story of an
apartment building in portland oregon
where we shoot grimm
and i don't know i don't know if that
cheer was for apartments
um
and i uh i sleep near the door and i
hear things happen in the hallway
whatever and there was like a bit of a
something kerfuffle that i kind of woke
to and didn't think of it and so i went
back to sleep
dreaming of sugar plums
and i woke up and there's a little note
under the door that just said
big fan
[Applause]
all right next step
um uh thank you for the question yeah i
mean i absolutely will watch the show
i'm a big fan as well as being in it and
um
and you know as i said the show will get
bigger and better and and just keep
going um and i'll follow it and they'll
get a brilliant actor and
yeah and and you know to know that it
carries on it's it's kind of lovely
because you you're part of a legacy that
doesn't
that doesn't die you know and i met you
know i've met peter and
tom baker and you know
who's very funny very funny man
um and it's yeah it keeps going i'm a
little in a big wheel you know
so i'll keep watching for sure
next that's a really good question
just just be respectful i think you know
um
i think that really goes a long way
i don't know man i mean i mean like
or just just be yourself yeah
definitely
just get a piece of paper
[Applause]
[Music]
my friend i love i love your bunny ears
as well
well i would love
um without wishing to sound too early
i just want to say thanks man because i
because who fans are particularly
extraordinary
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah too um so anyone who's a fan of
thrones out there
[Applause]
it's been a great i'm i'm with you on
this i'm i'm like it's been an amazing
journey for me and
i just want to say thank you for for
watching it and
yeah a big thank you and and i hope it
continues to satisfy you i hope you
it'll you'll keep enjoying it i think
you will i've just read season four this
[Laughter]
thank you
uh
for everyone um
just thank you as well uh
with in the walking dead we all try to
we work really really hard because we
know it's for you guys and you guys are
the ones that are supporting us and so i
wish you guys could see a glimpse into
this set of
how hard everyone goes from the
directors writers to the actors to every
single person
i'm sure that's true with everybody's
show it's just everybody goes so hard
and uh that's for you guys so thank you
very much
yeah uh i don't want to sound too cheesy
at your corner or anything but if you
guys
are i'm here because of you
and i wouldn't have that emotional
moment i just had without you guys and
it's just thank you for being so
supportive i've i feel so good that i
have so many supportive people in my
life and it's just it's the coolest so
really thank you guys
[Applause]
i mean ditto sincerely
i'm not about to say something silly um
except for the word silly
but um i think that it's so lovely um
you know
the show and people watching it is a
form of interaction
and i think that um we all appreciate
that
and we do
uh
you know the hours are long but we do it
for you guys because you're so awesome
and the best thing about like genre fans
is it's just like so sincere it's not
embarrassed about itself it's just a
wonderful wonderful group um to have
follow you and i i love each and every
one of my fans so thank you so much
that was a great question thank you um
[Music]
that was one of the hardest things i've
ever done physically it was a
year's worth of flames the first job i
got out of drama school i was very
very blessed it was at the national
theatre which we is a huge is a huge
deal for young actors
and um
i think the lesson that took away from
it was
and i i took this from drama school as
well but i didn't realize it until doing
a play for that long that
you have to be able to pour everything
into it you know you can't hold back
and you can't
you can't hold back from from going
there otherwise
you're cheating yourself you're cheating
the character you're cheating in the
audience and it's just to not be afraid
to to really push yourself until you're
nearly dead
um
but yeah that play is still going if
anyone
you know if anyone wants to go see it
you've got to go see it it's still going
it's still got great actors involved and
yeah it's um it was a very special part
of my of my young life um it's yeah so
thank you
next question
i want to say remember that scene from
monty python
i can't say that um
uh how would i want to die
um
which one with uh it's just a mere fresh
room
um
but
oh boy
it has to be big and whatever it is
it has to make me look
uh cool don't know i don't know
something medieval we we i have such a
great treasure trove of of weapons in
that trailer that nick has and
it's got to be one of those big
like beheadings with a big thing
tyler what do you think uh beheaded
would be cool
i think i think um
i think to fit with my my character i
think it would have to be
like going out while saving somebody
so
and uh and saving his friends loved ones
or a family member or whoever maybe even
a villain that would be kind of cool
yeah but uh but yeah i think that would
be a cool way to go out
steve how about you um it'd be cool if i
was riding a motorcycle and then while i
was riding the motorcycle i jump off a
ramp and then i kill like 30 walkers and
then explosion happens
and
my heart can't take the stress of how
awesome it was
[Applause]
and then i get out i um the bike i make
sure i put the kickstand down
and i dig my own grave and they just
fall asleep
[Applause]
on a sunday afternoon peacefully
85 years old
resting his head gently on the side of a
big fine chair
[Applause]
it's about to happen i mean it'd be cool
if i you know i was in the tardis and i
turned up and then i put my arms out and
loads of golden light pulled out of my
hands and my face
and then i turned into a woman i mean
[Applause]
and i went to the doctor a bit and i
tried to talk to loads of people and
they were like who's the weird bart
simpson
here
very positive
spider-man
[Applause]
uh luigi because i already look like him
david
an angry bird
[Applause]